what I see and engineering is that for
me it's a it's an art form it's an art
to have some idea some concept of a a
method some concept of a process and
concept of an instrument and bring those
pieces together out of your mind and
materialize them into real matter into a
real instrument into something that can
actually function hello I'm Cody Daniel
I'm 28 years old and the director of
research at three skin what got me into
this field and what got me into this
company is that I've always been
interested in making tools I grew up in
a house with a machinist as a father so
starting off from there I learned how to
make tools how to use tools how to use
them to change the world around me so I
always loved building tools building new
tools so I knew that I wanted to go into
an area where I can do instrumentation
and build new instruments and change the
way people interact with the world
around them better understand the
[Music]
three skin is building a set of tools
that allow us to better understand
biology the way we understand biology
today is still rooted in methods that we
developed over a hundred years ago
typically you stay in a piece of tissue
with some stained oil out some
contrasting feature you put it under a
microscope and you look at it the same
way we've done for centuries this method
is being augmented by things like
molecular tools that allow you to
understand the exact chemistry I was the
biology that's present unfortunately the
number of pathologist in the world is
shrinking and with a rising middle class
around the world we require a higher
level of care to be provided to more
people using fewer resources well my
company does is build automated tools
that allow us to understand pathology
using high speed microscopes automated
methods of sectioning an imaging tissue
as well as software methods of
interpreting those images to understand
the disease state of the tissue
underlying
[Music]
the challenge is not raising money it's
raising the right money because there's
a lot of money that would push you in
the wrong direction but you want to have
investors who are on your site who
understand you we've been very fortunate
with Lux and DC BC to have them pushing
toward pushing us towards a final goal
that lines up well with where we want to
go I think if we had investors who
didn't understand the long journey
involved
you take this thing that is so abstract
the concept of instrument and you turn
it into something that is so tactile a
tool that can actually serve a need and
that to me is like is like the greatest
art
Oh